ladies and gentlemen it's john's
birthday today
here's a photo of what he looked like
when he ran up the stairs
rushing to bring in some coffee and then
when he came in here i was like john you
get to choose
the video that we covered today oh yeah
and he said
this is a quote i want nothing more than
to watch
cosmic wonders spider-man no way home
leaks and details video so hit that like
button because
that's what you want to do exactly
verbatim the like button and subscribe
to the real rejects also subscribe to
the cosmic wonder yeah sure why not it's
your birthday
share it spread the love this is the
time check us out on patreon
come on over check me out i watch psych
on patreon agents of shield
which should come back to the mcu
multiverse very good
i'm in season five right now it's good
stuff almost at a minute that's not me
all right let's get into the video okay
good
that was smooth did i do it is it good
it's smooth
like butter and a criminal undercover
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel mcu
and of course spider-man no way home and
today we have some details about the
film
and some very very interesting leaks
these are somewhat unique to what we've
heard recently
and if one will be the judge of that
happens to be true it kind of explains
what
sony pictures universe of marvel
characters is actually doing
with venom and morbius and why the daily
bugle is the exact same daily bugle from
the sam raimi spider-man universe i
i just want to pause really quick just
tell you i appreciate
you warren going out of your way to
actually
i don't remember the acronym sp
sony pictures universe of marvel
characters i know i love that you're one
of the few who
really honors really honors that label
they
must love you sony and there is just a
whole dump of leaks on the internet
right now from people
claiming to have audition for the movie
therefore know
a little bit about a certain scene
others claiming that they know somebody
close to marvel studios or sony and they
heard a little bit about the film and if
one of these ends up being true we also
know a little bit more about the
relationship between sony and
marvel and the control that marvel has
over spider-man
which is always a great thing because
marvel knows what they're doing so there
is a ton to dive into today but before
we get started be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell so you don't
miss out on any of the latest spider-man
videos
so we'll start off by a pretty decent
credible source
the twitter account superhero theorists
seems to know a lot of the plot
of spider-man no way homeowner is what
this person is claiming
this person murphy's multiverse.com and
they have a pretty good reputation
with the scoops and the leaks that they
do put out there into the public
and based off of some of their recent
tweets we learn a little bit about the
film
one of them is another confirmation of
the main
villain of the film and the account that
originally tweets this the marvel
sheriff makes a pretty good point he
says
willem dafoe's norman osborne is in this
movie i'm having a hard time believing
daniel rpk
charles murphy the illuminati collider
and casey walsh all collectively got
false information about him being in the
movie
there's no denying this tweet reveals
and then charles murphy of murphy's
multiverse quote tweeted it saying he is
now i start by this and mention it
because this
is actually a very valid point all of
these scoopers mentioned
have been written about many different
scoops in the past even if they're not
100 correct on
everything they've put out nobody really
is but these people do have decent track
records
track records is what's important they
always interview people like marvel
studios president kevin feige
all of the actors for whatever movie or
show was coming up so they have a pretty
good relationship with marvel studios
disney etc etc
them combined with these other scoopers
who have good track records i would also
say that it's pretty much confirmed that
william defoe's norman osborne is indeed
going to be the main villain of this
film he's 100
in this movie he has to be i mean look
at that array i mean if i don't know i
mean not to say that collider is the
most reputable but out of that list it's
like scooper scooper oh dang like the
actual publication okay i first heard
about it from a news outlet yeah
one of the entertainment outlets yeah
like of all the things it seems like
this is happening what i don't believe
is when someone says i audition for it
so i know certain things
they give out scenes that aren't in the
movie they hire
lead actors without telling them stuff
that's the way it goes man you heard
andrew garfield's experience with even
amazing spider-man he didn't
audition with any real lines from the
script it was written just for the
auditions movie magic right there guys
but then we get a comment about
the multiverse one person tweeted the
fact that we are going to see these two
finally interact gets me so hyped
talking about willem the foes green
goblin slash norman osborne and dot god
in which superhero theorists replied the
film really is a love letter
to spider-man fans specifically to
raymie
and the amazing spider-man fans somebody
else went on to ask would you say it's
more of a love letter to those
spider-man
or all of them including tom's
spider-man
in which they replied i mean everyone
really but maybe raimi
and the amazing spider-man fans will
have the most fun
now to me this is really great
and andrew garfield spider-man from the
amazing spider-man universe aren't just
going to be
quick little five-minute six-minute
seven whatever minute cameos
they're not just going to pop up on the
screen for a second in one of dr
strange's portals and then
go away although i'm sure fans would
still be pretty excited about that even
just to see them in the movie but it
seems like
these characters and the characters from
their universes are actually going to be
pretty involved
another thing that this tells me is that
the leaks that we've been hearing about
the sinister six forming of villains
from other universes
is most likely true as well and it
really sounds like it's going to be just
an
awesome combination of all three
different spider-man universes
okay we put out a video earlier this
week
about our honest concerns with
spider-man no way home this is at the
point where you know nothing is 100
confirmed so there's like ways to kind
of scale the measurements here
for me i'm going off of like
what what i believe and
what i believe is that yeah they're
going to be at it that there will be
more
of these like this multiverse crossing
over stuff out for molina for sure and
all that but this kind of just goes
further to enhance the concern
of it doesn't feel like it's going to be
tom holland's movie yeah
he will be outshined by everything else
around him yeah it almost seems like
what do we do
to make the most you know crazy
definitive spider-man movie we have yet
we we go
backwards like i go backwards and focus
on these other things
yeah he's almost becoming like the
audience avatar with
less interesting features than everyone
else
which is not what you want for your mcu
peter parker like if they could find a
way to elevate him
through the use of the other spider-man
that would be cool that is a very strong
point
that's a very good birthday point a john
theory now these are pretty much details
out there about the movie but like i
mentioned in the beginning we do have
some leaks and they are pretty
interesting
the first one is about spider-man no way
home venom
and morbius essentially the spumc and
how it connects to the mcu spider-man
this leak states that the venom and
morbius movies are actually an
alternate version of the sam raimi
spider-man movies
this explains why the daily bugle logo
is exactly the same as in the rainy
movies
in this makes sense
yet spider-man hasn't met venom or eddie
brock
another difference is that in this
universe norman osborne never died
and what exactly happened to him after
the fight with spider-man i have no idea
this
is just what i was told as for dog och
it's pretty much what alfred molina said
that his character's story picked up
right after he fell into the water
now this is a very very interesting
thought and i would actually really
commend
sony if this is truly what they're doing
this kind of takes a lot of planning in
advance
however they have been working with
marvel studios for a while now
ever since civil war so it really
wouldn't surprise me at all if sony and
marvel and disney were all working
together to create this
huge universe or kind of two different
universes
because they definitely thrive off of
the success of one another sony
thrives more off of the success of
marvel obviously but it's really
beneficial to marvel if
sony films like venom and venom let
there be carnage and morbius do well and
connect and we have seen the original
daily bugle logo
in venom let there be carnage and we've
even seen it in some leaked photos for
morbius
so there is clearly a connection here
especially when you consider we have the
same
jj j jonah jameson in spider-man far
from home and the end credits and he's
going to be in spider-man
yeah that looks good yet another
alternate version so to me this makes
a lot of sense and even though i did
personally enjoy spider-man 3 i know
there are a lot of people out there who
didn't and you would
have that movie kind of erased also i'd
like to point out that if this leak
is true harry osborn is still alive and
has not died because they said
spider-man james
franco let's get a bone
that's what everyone wants the osborne
verse the hairy verse
everyone's been demanding james franco
return to spider-man franchise
you need another egg making scene you
see that
caught the basketball that actually
lines up pretty well
if it is to be believed with the
multiverse it's like there's alternate
realities about alternate realities or
certain realities it's just
you could pretty much explain your your
thing away
sometimes it could be just the littlest
thing is different in this reality or
this version of earth you know and they
got
a bunch of different earths and that and
i can't see a scenario here
where in conjunction with them doing
spider-verse but also beyond that with
their live-action films
clearly marvel is really stepping
heavily and if you've seen just even the
first episode of loki it's very obvious
we're really going to be diving deep
into like multiverses alternate
realities alternate versions and stuff
like that then you got like doctor
strange multiverse and madness so i
could see a
scenario where you do explain it away
that easily where basically you can have
like oh here's the reality where the
where tobey maguire is the spider-man
but the events of spider-man 3 didn't
happen that way you could still have
norman osborne alive but here's the
reality of this alpha molina is from
the actual spider-man yeah oh you know
you do you you could do a lot of that
yeah it makes sense and it seems like a
sensible way to both have all that fun
bringing those characters honor
those franchises kind of alleviate the
meme of all the reboots because stuff
didn't work
and not necessarily have to mess with
the original version of that exactly
you could bring in a very similar tobii
maguire spider-man with very similar
circumstances same for andrew garfield
it seems like the most respectful way
almost to
do all this one of the concerns that we
were having was about
ruining legacy or undoing the characters
journeys from the previous
installments the ones that we liked at
least yeah
that was the concern there come to think
of it there were all these rumors
circulating it seemed like they were at
least courting emma stone
to be in this film as well perhaps when
we see what's going on with andrew
garfield spider-man that would make
sense like
okay in this version of andrew garfield
spider-man gwen stacy gotta live
and think too like the surprise it could
be of like depending on which version of
toby maguire gets snatched up maybe it's
a surprise to him that norman osborne's
still alive
yeah maybe they snatch up the one who
witnessed him die that seems like the
most plausible way to go about it but
it's also exciting to think
if it's not and if they're just sequels
from the other ones yeah it's like both
versions work
one i'm more concerned about the other
one's a much safer bet
yeah yeah yeah absolutely but the one
i'm concerned about if that is done
right
is exciting yeah and i would personally
love for a
james franco cameo and spider-man no way
home but i'm not getting my hopes up
this next leak comes from somebody who
claims to have auditioned for a role in
spider-man no way home and didn't get it
but one of his friends
did and that role was the role of a
juror this leak says i tried out for the
jury in no way home
didn't get the part but his best friend
persisted and was cast as a juror and
saw
a certain blind man representing tom as
well as
separate shots mentioning she-hulk in
case dd
rights as in daredevil weren't cleared
but it seems daredevil scenes will be
used without a doubt
didn't see a costume but he was a dang
good lawyer now this kind of lines up
with what we've heard before
he's probably the same situation as
norman osborn enough
trade companies have reported that matt
murdock is going to be in the movie
that i'm really expecting it at this
point it's not confirmed by any means
but it just seems to make sense and
would be really really cool to see he's
a lawyer in new york he's a superhero on
the side but they don't reveal that he's
a superhero but it would make sense that
he would want to defend
another superhero and literally every
report that we have
states that it's not daredevil showing
up but matt murdock he's not going to be
donning his costume he's simply going to
be a lawyer
now this next leak is very interesting
because it talks about the relationship
between sony and marvel studios and of
course we always want to know what's
going on with these
guys and what's posted actually seems
pretty legitimate this person claims
that they're an affiliation
in some way with a toy manufacturer so
working for a victory company
and this person says so basically i've
been hearing rumors that marvel has more
control over the spider-man no way home
film
and i can in fact confirm that usually
for the previous films me and my boss
would have
around a three-hour meeting with one of
the guys over at sony but this time
we had the meeting with sony the same
guy who came for the far from home
meeting back in early 2019
and a guy from marvel this time they
ordered like four sets for the film and
another set for the new spider-man ride
opening up at disneyland
they were very secretive about this film
and my colleague who helped design the
in-game sets thinks they probably gave
us fake things to make sets off of like
they did with in-game
so this is a very specific leak that i
don't think a lot of people
would sit there and make up or even come
up with and if it's true
that's incredibly good news for us that
means marvel studios and disney
but if it's fake that's a damn good
that's a really good someone sat around
like what's the best job this last time
that i'm about to mention i'm gonna go
ahead and put a disclaimer out stating
that i don't believe it but it is rather
interesting to think
about so i thought why not just put the
thought out there now in case
for some random reason this is true i'm
not going to go too much into detail but
it basically states that loki is going
to be playing a pretty decent part in
spider-man no way home
this is because of the events that
happen in the loki series
obviously time travel is involved and
some type of alternate timelines and the
multiverse is involved in loki and who
knows how it's going to end and the
events probably
aren't going to lead into spiderman no
way home however i just don't think
loki's going to be in the movie
that is just too much at that point but
then again there's so much in it why not
just throw one
after all doctor strange did say in thor
ragnarok that he was monitoring loki
and they have met so maybe there are
definitely plenty of ways to make
this work and it could actually make
sense but to me it's just so much
in one movie that i'm really not
counting on this but like i said we had
a lot of spider-man knowing home news
and
leaks today so be sure to let me know
what you think about all of this in the
comments down below
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching
never lose that catchphrase ever john
what did you enjoy warden's video as
your birthday present i had a blast with
this video
do you know what people have all kinds
of opinions about spider-man leaks but
for this movie i don't even care if any
of them are true they're just fun
they're fun to entertain they're fun to
pick apart from
40 looks good on you buddy i am glad to
be 40. finally this is 40.
hey guys john's gonna choose someone to
do a
who is your favorite person in the whole
world that you want to do a patron of
the day shout out for to make everyone
else feel
less than oh my goodness i guess it has
to be
oh were you setting me up for one does
anyone
miss a veer anyone at all yeah all right
well then today
i want to shout out the man gene jeter
because
gene you are a photographer
i'm sure for a second i was like i bet
it's this guy but then i i wanted to
pivot because
gene you seem like the perfect person to
play
someone working at the daily bugle in
one of these movies you're a creative
good
italian yeah that's a good shout out
john
because gene's a photographer that's a
good shot a keen
eye and think about it if gene got bit
by some kind of radioactive bug
he would be photographing himself all
over town and you know those things
would be beautiful he could not only
sell them to the daily bugle he could
sell prints of them online
like on those where they take a photo
and they make it look like a painting
you could do it gene yes and
i hope you're having a good my birthday
you